[Music]
hello and welcome to is that how it
starts you dear to Hank and John hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John who
rose up really good Dear John and Hank
it's a company podcast where me and my
brother John answer your questions give
you two beasts advice and bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon today we're in real life we're
together we there is no need for you to
pretend that we are in the same room
because we are in fact in the same room
right now in the great state of Florida
it occurs to me that they might not even
be pretending they might actually think
that we are in the same room and in some
ways maybe we aren't we're just in some
kind of third space that we visit on the
phone it is a other room yes a room made
of electrons I'm fascinated by the
spaces that we make up or sort of like
make physical what was once called
cyberspace before it became so assumed
that it that we stopped thinking about
it a space do you ever have that
experience where you will have a very
intense interaction in a online space
and then later you will ascribe it to a
physical place no that happens to me as
happened to me several times really
where they're like big moments that I
have happened in my life that were
happened on the Internet but I feel like
they happened and I have I put them in a
physical space that I've been to before
so I think of them as occurring in that
space one of the only three times I ever
vomited entirely from stress or fear or
emotion was from a cyberspace
interaction like with my girlfriend at
the time we'd met on the internet and
she how do we look good good
hank is looking at the levels right now
my girlfriend and I were sort of
in this middle of this long six-month
breaking up process and we just had a
very tough conversation and immediately
after I like it was almost like hanging
up back then going offline was an action
in a way that it isn't now and I I just
went to the immediately went to the
bathroom and threw up in our house back
in Winter Park Florida
well that never has happened to me I
don't think I've ever puked from emotion
really yeah I've puked from emotion a
few times I puked from reading once Wow
yeah I've never puked from drinking
either
I've also beaut from drinking ah I have
food for the other reasons just from
illness illness yeah and motion sickness
oh you know it's been a long time since
I puked from motion sickness I
remembered being a very unpleasant
beautiful not good it is not a good puke
right should we should we should we talk
about Florida or should we move on to
diplomas well yeah I feel like we should
do with the how how are you doing today
John I'm doing well I am in the midst of
somewhat crazy a few days for me yeah I
was just in New York talking to Bill and
Melinda Gates for the launch of their
annual letter which is fantastic you can
read it at gates letter calm and know
they didn't pay me to say that going
Lynda gates not sponsors at this bond
I've got it they've got the money they
cook their answer did they chose not to
believe it they're spending their money
in smarter ways and and then I'm here
for about a day and then I'm going on a
trip to visit some refugee camps for the
rest of the week which will be very
interesting so you can actually talk
about that now but on my way oh yeah I'm
gonna stop off in London for seven hours
and go to a Nancy wimbledon game ah your
life exhausts me how are you doing Hank
I'm good I think I feel like I just
going to Florida for a vacation it's
just an awful lot for me you're like
you're like the Florida vacation was
just like sort of a six-hour layover on
your way to Tunisia or something
so we we grew up here Hank grew up here
more than I did but we both kind of grew
up here and every time I land in Florida
like when I'm flying over Florida and
the plane lands and then I get out into
the airport and everything
I always think and this is the stupidest
thought but I have it every single time
I land in Florida there is no place on
earth like Florida more like floor now
like it's just those four it's the floor
deist place in the world it is very
Florida it's that old Florida well
especially the Gulf Coast yeah
everything's pastel oh my god there's
all kinds of Kichi sculpture gardens and
there's this there's there's whimsy oh
there's so much whimsy and seashells if
I have to describe the Gulf Coast in two
words it would be whimsy , seashells
yeah it's good
not whimsy seashells no no no because
the seashells are very serious all right
let's move on to a poem okay I wanted to
read you this poem last week it's rise
it was any recent vlogbrothers video
have you read Octavia Butler yeah
have you read the parable of the sower
no you've got to read that one it's the
best I've gone on to now read like six
Octavia Butler books in the last two
weeks but this one was this one was
maybe my favorite so it's from parable
of the sower and it's very short poem
today the shortest of the short poems no
not the shortest we've ever done but
near in order to rise from its own ashes
a Phoenix first must burn it's good
right uh-huh Octavia Butler man one of
America's great novelists and one I
hadn't even ever read until like six
months ago hmm
yeah yeah
Phoenix burn I never know what to say
after poems just think about it in
silence everyone together I just think
it's not even really a poem it's just an
observation just a fact about Phoenix's
you know what AFC Wimbledon's badges is
it a Phoenix
that makes sense makes sense because
they had they had to they had to burn
yeah where they could rise from their
own ashes
and I feel like just even just because
it's so it's such a nice image and it's
a good colors that I would maybe want to
wear and I have c1 buildin scarf if it
were cool out well if that is the case
you can always go to dftba.com where
Antonis cards are for sale and and the
the proceeds from those scarves go to
benefit AFC Wimbledon a football club
owned by its fans and arguably the
greatest fourth tier English Football
Club in the history of football and
maybe maybe soon the greatest little bit
they're the greatest all right that's
good let's get there let's let's go to
some questions for mark alright beloved
listeners who emailed us of Hank and
John gmail.com hey can we start off with
with me asking a question sure
alright this question comes from Miranda
who writes Dear John and Hank it
wouldn't be dear Hank and John without
some talk about death so with the recent
passing of Justice Scalia I realize I
know nothing about how the Supreme Court
selection process works
don't worry Miranda Congress also knows
nothing about it
why does it take so long to elect a new
justice they aren't elected that's part
of the reason why aren't there backups
already lined up like a u.s.
vice-president has a vice president
that's a great question maybe they
should have thought of that when they
were making the constitution why are
there more specific guidelines in place
as to who should select a replacement in
an election year
Miranda those are excellent questions
and they are all questions that I wish
our founding parents mostly fathers had
borne in mind when they were writing the
United States Constitution here are some
other things I wish they'd borne in mind
while we are discussing it um I wish
they borne in mind that while we weren't
going to be part of the United Kingdom
anymore their Parliament it's actually a
pretty high functioning organization and
maybe we should have adopted a
parliamentary system instead of adopting
the absolutely bananas congressional
system that we currently have some of
this is about the fact that the
Constitution is extremely vague about
the Supreme Court it says that Supreme
Court justices will be chosen by the
president with but with the advice and
consent
sent of the Senate that's all it says
this is not really what if that's pretty
much my bison consent and a Senate this
year hasn't interpreted that to mean
over the years that has meant different
things it used to be before about like
1960 I think it used to be that the
president just chose the Supreme Court
justices and then Congress said as you
wish or or yeah I guess that's I guess
consent implies that they could say no
somehow but they didn't actually figure
out that they could say no until like
1960 okay ah one of the weirder things
that happened in the US Supreme Court is
that when Franklin Delano Roosevelt was
president he wasn't pleased with what
the Supreme Court was doing and none of
the Supreme Court justices were dying so
he just decided that the Supreme Court
should have more justices and he
appointed a bunch of new people to the
Supreme Court was called packing the
court and that's how he got all of the
New Deal legislation through so it would
be really fascinating if if we just kept
doing that because then there would be
as many Supreme Court justices as there
are Congress people or as many Supreme
Court justices as there there are
Americans we could all be on the Supreme
Court so yeah I want to back up and for
a second I just bet that we're gonna get
a lot of feedback from our British
viewers about how their Parliament does
not function well I mean you can say
that their Parliament doesn't function
well but come on I mean well we're
comparing it to America's yeah an unrest
there's much the well I think what the
idea of the parliamentary system that is
effective is that the the party that has
the most most seats in parliament is
able to elect is able to choose its
leader and that person becomes the prime
minister rather than potentially having
a president and a Congress who
profoundly intensely hate each other and
see there being a great deal right
political hay to be made from hating
each other that's true that's I hadn't
thought about that yeah and it does seem
like it does not work out super well
because oftentimes you get the you get
the president from one party and then
everybody pushes back and then lets
Congress from the other party now the
alternate argument is that basically the
the United States was set up to be a
country in which it was extremely
difficult to do anything
yeah and that it has been that and that
it is often benefited from being that
rather than you know now going populist
in this direction or populist in that
direction I mean essentially the u.s.
revolution was this extremely
conservative revolution in which yeah
one group of rich white land owning men
exchanged control of the United States
with a slightly different but largely
identical group of rich white land
owning men and I think a lot of both the
I think a lot of the problems of the
United States since then were sort of
sealed into the into the cake we're sort
of linked in yeah from the very
beginning right but also you know it's
gone okay the United States has been an
incredibly successful country and one of
the reasons that our revolution was a
successful revolution is because it was
a reasonably conservative one versus
like you look at the French Revolution
which was so radical that in the end it
wasn't sustainable and so you know they
went from having one one despot named
Louie to one despot named Napoleon right
so back to the Supreme Court yeah the
president gets to pick one and the
Congress gets to approve it after post
Nixon negativity they get to advise and
consent although in this case they are
refusing to advise and also pre refusing
to consent and they are preemptively
refusing to consent I think the proper
response to this to be honest what I
would love to have happen is I would
love to have President Obama nominate a
moderate mm-hmm moderate justice yes and
then have Congress approve it that is
not going to happen for a variety of
reasons Congress is able to make is able
to cite precedent for what they're doing
the president is able to cite precedent
for why this is crazy the truth is
that we should have prepared an answer
to this problem at some point in the
last 230 years and we really haven't now
I think I'm you know everybody brings
their own bias to this I think I would
like to think that even if the president
were someone with whom I disagreed
politically that you know with 330 days
left in office that president should be
allowed to appoint a Supreme Court
justice and I think I would think that
regardless of my own political opinions
but it's hard to know because because
you can't see past your own biases yeah
yeah well fascinating
here's American history the Constitution
is not perfect and nor in fact is it
very clear a lot of yeah there are also
a lot of things that we're glad we've
changed I've got another question
everybody's glad we changed about the
Constitution it's very weird to me when
people think that the Constitution is
some kind of you know like the founding
fathers were gods of some sort and they
passed down this document that is
perfect in every way anyway I have
another question John and probably is
time to move on so that was a pretty
long one and as usual packed with comedy
there's a question is from Lane who says
dear Hank of John I need help with hugs
hmm as I've gotten older I've started to
hug more people outside of my family you
and I can't say that I'm very good at it
yeah I love a good hug but I don't
always know how to go about giving one
yeah my question is this when you go to
hug someone else do your arms go above
or under the person's arms or does it go
over one shoulder and under the other
arm does it change with different
genders in different situations I have
no idea well Hank is much more of a
hugger than I am I have lots of opinions
on that yeah and you'll recall that one
time the President of the United States
attempted to shake Hanks hand ahead no
sir
we are going to hug yeah well he just
hugged two other people but he extended
his hand to you and you were like I'm
coming in mr. president I figured I I
thought that people would say the
president is a sexist if he hugged too
women and then shook the hand of a man
I'm inclined to agree I thought you made
the right call but for sure yeah and
he's in very fees very fit by the way
yeah so yes I there is no wrong way to
hug but it is like a handshake in that
you kind of can tell things about people
by their hugs and I I think that in
general a hug should be firm and not
uncomfortable and where the arms end up
going is is almost entirely up to
circumstance and that often has to do
with height if there's a great height
differential yeah then you're gonna go
around the middle and they're gonna go
over the top mm-hmm and that that
happens and this doesn't happen to me
very often to some I'm fairly tall but I
have a friend who's like six eight and
you and I hug him I go I go I don't try
to get my hands up over one of his
shoulders oh I do when I had my best
friend is six seven and when I hug him I
go one hand over the shoulder even
though even as dumb as it looks you can
hide it up there it's not just that it
looks dumb I feel like I'm like at a
middle school dance which was the last
time like my peers were so much taller
than I was yeah no yeah and so you're
the boys who were always shorter than
the girls back then we're supposed to be
right we were supposed to have our arms
on their shoulders and they're supposed
to have their hands on our waist we just
looked ludicrous yeah and I feel like
that every time I hug Chris I think to
myself I'm just a I'm a middle school
boy at a dancing yeah yeah so uh and I
will find myself going up on tiptoes and
I'm hugging at him and and trying to get
one hand over his shoulder but and I do
feel a little bit odd I will say now
that I'm thinking about it when I give
when I give him a hug because I feel
kind of like a little girl and I'm just
like cuddling into his chest but I I
think that it's mostly down to height
where your arms end up if you're roughly
the same height you do one over and then
like and you sort of like you know you
you did the whole process of giving a
hug you to have this
wind up where you pull your arms out
while you're still a fair distance away
yeah and that's the time when you're
like using your weird monkey brain to
figure out where my arms are gonna end
up yep and if do you do that dance and
you're at hands keep matching each other
and then then you got
like you just eventually you will get
close enough and there will be enough of
the difference that you'll end up in a
hug and it will be okay yeah you know
Elaine what I would say is that I always
let the other person based on the way
that they hold out their hands for the
hug I let the other person dictate and
maybe this means that I'm too passive
or I'm never going to be successful in
business or something but I let the
other person dictate the terms of the
hug um and if I find that they are like
me and not a hug term dictator what I do
in that situation is I just go right arm
up left arm down right
just as that's sort of the natural
that's my in an emergency this person
also doesn't even lead the hug I'm gonna
go right arm up left arm down so that
would be my recommendation what do you
think about body contact and a hug I'm
not crazy about body contact in a hug I
think hugs are mostly for arms and
collarbones I deeply disagree I just I
feel like I feel like your toes should
touch your knees to touch your hips
should touch your chest your judge here
no all right all the way down I like to
admit I mean if I'm hugging my wife but
like I or my kids or something but no I
like to minimize touching yes bodily
contact I do i do just jetting can we
move on to a question about Mars yeah
sure I thought I could get you off the
topic of hugs by bringing up Mars all
right I take this questions from Neda
who asks Dear John and Hank a few
podcasts ago Hank said Martian winter
and that got me thinking does all of
Mars have winter at the same time or is
it like Earth where the northern and
southern hemispheres have it at
different times does Mars have
hemispheres or an equator I'd love to
know what the seasons are like on Mars
and if it depends on where you are
I love the podcast it is the highlight
of my week and I think absolutely
hilarious
Netta you do not have a very good sense
of humor
well but we appreciate the sentiment
anyways yeah Mars is just like Earth it
has an axial tilt like Earth's and thus
it has seasons like Earth it has a
winter and one hemisphere and then while
it's summer in the other hemisphere and
all planets have hemispheres the the
equator is defined by the spin of the
planet so where it sits the you know
when the planet is spin I'm doing hand
gestures now so this is this is a visual
thing look on the internet you can see
what a hemisphere is it's half way down
and the sphere yeah half way found the
city almost like it's that hemisphere
exactly yeah but there's that like for
example Uranus spins on its side and and
so it's it's the timah spheres are left
and right not top and bottom
you're never gonna say Uranus without me
laughing at you ever that's fine we need
to remove that planet but there would be
so there would be planets that there
there could be a planet that doesn't
have winners like that that would be
perfectly 90 degrees with the plane of
the solar system
and I don't know if there are any
planets like that that probably are but
so I think Mercury's like that would you
be better off like so you could you
could do what you could do in the United
States where you spend you know summer
in New York yeah and then you're like oh
it's starting to get cold I'm gonna go
to Sydney Australia and enjoy more
summer yeah you can totally do that
except that instead of summer it would
just be a little bit less frigid I might
get up to like you might get up but I
mean in addition to never being able to
go outside because there's no air mm-hmm
you would you would you know you're
never gonna get up much up you're not
gonna give above freezing I don't think
ever on the surface of Mars really yeah
that sounds miserable well you know I
live in Montana where it doesn't get
above freezing for quite a quite a hunk
of the year but but does have air though
I just think air is such an important
part of what makes Earth enjoyable it is
a big part of what makes Earth enjoyable
do you want to know another part of what
makes to Earth enjoyable I do the
question is from Gavin who asked
dear Hank and John cows eat grass yep so
why don't people it's cheap and easy to
grow so shouldn't everyone just eat
grass grow a thing that makes earth
great no they shouldn't eat grass and
I'll tell you why
so humans need certain things protein
fiber all things item is also also in
grass
it's a calorie inefficient food verses
like our agriculture staples like rice
potatoes yes it is it does not have as
much energy in it man
ok alternately it there is a reason
there is a reason what is the reason
well first we're not cows well I
understand that we're not calves but
what is the reason if it is energy as
energy intensive and as digestible by Z
naught as digestible so that's what I
mean that's the thing you have just as
much energy in grass which is why you
can burn grass and there will like dry
grass and there will be it'll be energy
released basically what's happening in
our bodies is just a slow burn of all
the things that we eat but there are
certain things that our bodies are not
metabolically set up to digest and
cellulose is one of those things whereas
in a cow's body they can convert that
cellulose which is just made up of
sugars but sugars bonded together in a
particular way they can break that
cellulose down into those sugars and
then use those sugars the way that we
would use sugar as fuel we cannot do
that and and we cannot do that because
we don't have the same digestive system
as a cow and also because cows actually
I'm pretty sure don't break down
cellulose themselves they do it with
with bacteria in their guts and that's
why they have like a bunch of different
chambers because they have this whole
fermentation thing happening with a
bunch of different bacterial colonies
that are turning that cellulose into
fuel for a cow so each of accounts for
different stomachs as a different is
colonized by different bacteria I've bet
I bet it is no that is not a thing that
I know for sure but it seems very likely
to me follow-up question what percentage
of a cow
is actually bacteria I would guess that
the number of cells yeah of bacteria
there are more bacterial cells than cow
cells in a cow really I I would just get
certainly by weight again by weight it's
gonna be almost entirely cow but by
number of cells because bacteria cells
are much smaller than cow cells but I
don't think of myself I don't think of
myself when I think of what constitutes
me I do not think of the number of
pounds that the cells I think of as me
way mm-hm I think of this number of
cells that are me and that's closer I
think to what I am than then a number on
a scale that could fluctuate wildly so
the thought that I am actually and yes
you're gonna see a lot of this in my new
book the thought that I am actually only
half me it's distressing well there's
the question are you even half you what
cells count as being you that's a great
question right because if you cut off
your you know you thank you finger
you're still you yeah even though you've
lost this part of you so then really
it's mostly brain stuff it isn't but it
isn't entirely brain stuff because I
would already said like if you had to
print system stuff as well if you had a
traumatic brain injury right now like
your personality would be different you
would be you would be different in right
and important in central ways but I
would still think of you as you right
and you would still be you right so the
actual I mean this is it's just like
fiendishly complicated that's all I can
say about yes yes I do sometimes feel
like I just have all of these like sort
of meat parts to the me that are
necessary to like hold on to stuff and
move around
well yeah but I know my ear you noises
with my mouth I will remind you that
your brain is also made of meat okay
here's a question from Johanna who asks
Dear John and Hank my name is Johanna
I'm from Berlin and I'm not a native
English speaker and only thirteen years
old so I apologize in advance for any
grammatical mistakes that I'm going to
you made none in that sentence here's my
question :
that's appropriate I've been a
nerdfighter for two to three years now
and as the John bobblehead first came
out I was just a little kid and didn't
even know you existed so when the John
and Hank bobblehead collection came out
I was really happy and bought them this
is the best email in terms no Rama yeah
I have ever read I really love them but
John fell down yesterday and
unfortunately his head fell off sorry
for your headaches John
she even put the parentheses and the
period in the right place I don't have
the money to buy another set so do you
have any idea how I could fix John thank
you for your dubious advice and don't
forget to be on some best wishes
I mean first off never again apologize
for your grammar Johannah English or in
German because that was phenomenal that
is I can only hope that seven years from
now my son will be able to write in any
language that well okay so first off how
to fix the the head falling off of a
bobble head problem Hank we've talked
about some big problems and news vodka
whether you are you whether there should
be a Supreme Court justice
over the next three hundred and thirty
days or whether we should just leave
that seat empty inexplicably for an
entire freaking year sorry that was that
revealed some bias we've talked about
Martian hemispheres we've never talked
about anything is important as how to
reattach a bobble head which make all of
that preamble makes me feel like you
just have no idea do you know I do know
oh okay well gee what's your thought
okay so you got it what you got to do to
win is you got a glue the very top of my
neck mm-hmm you've got to put super glue
on the top not on the sides on the top
right of the neck because that's how
they do it in the first place and then
you put the head very carefully back on
to the neck and you should be able to
retain a percentage at least of the
bobble right I would say close but I I'm
gonna suggest instead of super glue
which has no flex it dries extremely
strong but but hard I would say
something like rubber cement or caulk
okay so that you can get something that
we'll be happy moving around a lot yeah
alternately just get a new bubble head
city comm I don't suggest that
definitely repair rather than replace
when possible today's podcast is brought
to you by John and Hank bobbleheads
available now at dftba.com for the low
low price of just 35 dollars might be 40
we're not sure something around there
today's podcast is also brought to you
by Franklin Delano Roosevelt's Supreme
Court justice stacking of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt's Supreme Court justice
tacking responsible for the New Deal and
possibly all of current American
prosperity
that's a bold bold step of dubious some
of America's prosperity some percentage
of American prosperity might be able to
be traced back to bet it's one of those
things where if it had gone wrong we
would remember it oh yeah Ike as like
you know this power grab by the first
president to be elected four times he
was essentially president for life yeah
it was them now again and today's
podcast is also brought to you by
Martian summer summer on Mars still
incredibly cold and finally this podcast
is brought to you by cellulose mmm
that component of grass that's made of
sweet and tasty wonderful sugar but as
somehow yet still inaccessible to us
because we are not sufficiently made of
bacteria I got another question this one
is from a Lynne who asks dear Hank and
John I'm a listener from the
french-speaking part of Belgium like
most of my friends though I consume a
lot more english-speaking media be it
books TV shows movies YouTube videos etc
than french-speaking ones for my point
of view here in Europe it seems that
especially in the internet era culture
from the english-speaking world most of
the USA automatically has a wider reach
and as seen as cooler more relevant or
simply better this is making it more
difficult for non-english speaking
creators to compete and reach an
audience I'm worried about what this
means for diversity while I love the
American and other english-speaking
media I consume I still want to hear
about other cultures including my own
this is a great
point and I forget about it because
obviously we do have it big you know you
and I have a big audience overseas
especially in in Europe in places where
they don't speak English as a first
language but a lot of people speak
English nonetheless yeah I like the
number of people in Europe speaking
English just continues to rise yeah but
I think it's a big problem for internet
culture in general because because the
internet feels so big and it feels so
inclusive a lot of times we forget that
there that the vast majority of people
can't participate in online discourse at
least in the Internet's lingua franca
which is currently English so you know
you're taught so when we talk about you
know Internet discourse we're excluding
people who don't speak English at least
when we're talking about the kind of
Internet discourse that I engage and I'm
excluding people who don't speak English
I'm excluding people who don't have
regular access to the same Internet
tools that I use which most of which are
dependent upon broadband and so you end
up excluding most people yeah as you
feel like you feel like you're being
inclusive you feel like you're listening
to voices that aren't you know
systemically silenced but in fact like
you're participating in a tool that is
further the furthering the systemic
silence of many voices and in many cases
the most vulnerable voices not the
french-speaking part of Belgium I'm
thinking but you know more of you know
places where poor country communities
where people don't have access to those
tools I think the first thing that that
I'm in favor of is more content in more
languages I spoke to when I was in Davos
Switzerland I spoke to a lot of Internet
entrepreneurs in sub-saharan Africa and
the number one thing that they said was
that yes we need Internet connectivity
we also need content we need something
to connect to we don't have a ton of
content yeah we don't have a ton of
high-quality content that's I have a
friend who has gone over to several
places in the developing world to and I
we actually nerdfighter community a long
time ago worked together to get some
equipment for her
to bring over there so that they could
like so that she could teach people how
to make content and I was sort of
focused on photojournalism at first but
then also documentary film and and like
documentary film in sort of Internet
style which becomes just you know
another kind of YouTube video and it was
amazing to me both like sort of like
what she was able to do in terms of
teaching people who then taught other
people and also how inexpensive it was
for her to go do that I mean obviously
like there's more than that the dollar
cost like also it's just a difficult and
time-consuming thing to do to take like
a piece of your you know your career
away to go and spend this time doing
some B's not gonna make you a bunch of
money but it was a fascinating to see
now but I'm gonna and like and I really
am excited about hopefully hoping that
more of that gets done and and that you
know there are a lot of people who have
more experience creating for the
Internet and hopefully those people will
share those tools with the rest of the
world now it was really interesting to
me in this question something I hadn't
even thought about is that Ellen says
it's cooler to watch English stuff right
which is really interesting to me like
how that might get tied up and but like
I have noticed as I've been trying to
watch the YouTube communities of other
countries that a lot of places in Europe
don't have that many native YouTube like
interesting YouTube things happening
there are some but not tons yeah and and
that's I think Parc partially because
European culture and American culture
are different but much more similar than
other cultures are across the world
yeah and and so like there's there's
probably a lot of connection that's
pretty easy and then there's also like
you already see that this stuff is
popular like you know that like people
are liking this they have a ton of
subscribers whether it's Dan and Phil or
PewDiePie and you like of course it's
like the easiest path is to go with the
thing that's already popular there's
also a culture built around those those
creators as well you know like there's
fan art that might have access to like
and that makes you feel like you're a
part of the thing yeah it makes and it
makes the whole world more enjoyable it
makes the fan community more enjoyable
you don't have to like build that stuff
from scratch I think there might be
something special about watching
somebody who's a little bit different
from you in the same way that people
like watching PewDiePie because like
like you know he's a really talented
funny guy who also has you know that
extra spice of not being American right
this is a big issue in my other life in
publishing because in the u.s. very very
little was published in translation and
even less is read in translation I mean
Americans are just waffle at reading
books translated from other language
interesting except for the girl with the
dragon tattoo but good that one yeah we
did we like we do in general we actually
do Scandinavian mystery novelists fairly
well yeah but everything else we're
really bad we also converted the Harry
Potter novels into American that's true
we took the you the you out of color and
made it Sorcerer's Stone just to confuse
everyone in the whole world and I hear a
lot from my readers in Europe that they
that they want to read the books in
English so they like reading them in
English because they want to read them
the way that I intended them to be rant
but so my counter-argument to that is
that it if you don't think in English
you kind of can't read it in a way that
I intended it to be read and in fact
like in some ways that idea the way I
intended it to be read is to me at least
a flawed idea like I don't think that I
I wasn't thinking of it being read in an
in an intended or an unintended way
exactly when I was writing it I and
people always talk about how translation
makes books worse I would argue that
lots of times translation makes books
better to like it's just as possible
that a translator can improve a novel as
as make one worse and and I see that in
my career like I see there are places
where my translators are so good that my
books are compared to books that are
much much better than like in Germany
especially you know a lot of times
Sophie sites is my translator there and
she's a brilliant translator and and one
you know and so my books they're
compared to Philip Roth and Jonathan
Fran
Tony Morrison but I'm just like what did
you do yeah clearly like That's not me
clearly like a Sophie is doing something
to my novels that's making them very
very good good so I I think I guess what
I would encourage you to do is to find
find content in your language and
celebrate it right you know and
interestingly Canada actually has rules
with national broadcasting that you have
to include a certain amount of Canadian
content and that's not something you can
do with the internet you force a certain
amount of people to watch a certain
amount of content from inside the
country right and the problem you run
into is all of these European single
language markets non English markets are
going to be definitionally smaller than
the English language market which is
huge because of America also because
lots of people who don't speak English
as a first language do speak English and
so if you have a smaller market it's
harder to make money and then it's
harder to make a living and it's harder
to you know like to increase your
production values and so a lot of what
you know it's just a much more difficult
path for creators and kind of what we
need is people to like content
specifically because it's less popular
and when people whenever somebody like
is sort of gives that that sentiment a
hard time for being like hipster II I
I'm like well how else is anything new
ever going to get discovered because you
have to like something that's different
in new and and there's something
wonderful and freeing creatively about
not having a huge audience that allows
for interesting things to happen
creatively that we have to have an
audience a certain percentage of people
who are always looking for something
that is into the mainstream not just
because it's you know not just because
like it's not the mainstream but also
because more like creative interesting
creative things happen more easily
outside of the mainstream yeah I totally
agree the last thing that I would say
about this is I have a friend who calls
this the Lithuanian poet problem that if
you are a Lithuanian poet your chances
of winning a Nobel Prize your chances of
finding a wide audience are so
infinitesimally small compared to if
your
writing in English or even in German or
French that it's it almost discourages
you from ever starting because in and
it's in a very small country or a
relatively small language it can be hard
even if you find success to make a
living because there just aren't that
many potential customers for your work
and this is a kind of privilege that we
almost never talk about but it's it's an
intensely important kind of privilege
and like one of I would argue like one
of the most one of the most important
but but because it's so important and
because it's so omnipresent it's easy
not to look at like err like it's easy
to just feel like it's on the air but
it's not in the air writing in English
is a massive structural advantage and
you know being able to read in English
is a massive structural advantage and
those are things that we have to be
conscious of all right John this is the
part of the podcast where we talk about
news I think the news from AFC Wimbledon
well that and also the news from marks a
cold dead rock in the middle of space
correct or maybe not dead
maybe not but probably dead well but but
if it but if it were alive John yes that
would be to be clear yeah
the biggest news ever in the history of
humanity no that's not the news today
though also I would argue that it would
not be the biggest news in the history
of humanity really yes in the history
you think that life on that that life we
are not alone in the universe
yeah would not be the biggest news no
what if it was what if there was a
person who is not a human a sentient
yeah person yeah like a Wookiee yeah I
go with Mars had Wookiees yeah that
we're living in underground tunnels yes
that would be the biggest news in human
is okay this make Mars one
bacteria yeah that might have come from
Earth well we'll be able to figure that
out all right if Mars has life separate
from Earth that evolved separately from
life on Earth right would it be the
biggest news in human history I'm gonna
say hard no but I'm gonna say it would
be in the top 200 news stories in human
history but I would also argue that AFC
Wimbledon's returned to the football
league in 2011 was one of the top 200
news stories of all time I mean you get
that's them that's the thing about
arguing the printing press you can
literally argue anything the
Agricultural Revolution the Columbian
Exchange AFC Wimbledon's victory over
Luton Town in the 2011 play-off final
like they're there are the problem is
there are a bunch of big stories right
so it's hard to pick which is the
biggest all right do your news no you do
yours first I have important news the
bad news is that I somehow while walking
up you lost the news Ammar into the
internet list area of this house ah it's
just it's this Popular Mechanics asking
me to submit my email address first time
you did go - no thanks just hit the X oh
thank you John so good at navigating the
energy you're really good at the
Internet we've got a news story here the
u.s. is investigating what's called
photonic propulsion mm-hmm which could
potentially send a spacecraft to Mars in
as little as three days and the current
technology we'd be looking at like a
year a year together little less than a
year depends on the time of year you
leave depends on the route you take sure
but so it's a big problem in space
travel as we always say is you have to
haul the fuel to move the fuel to move
the fuel right to move the fuel to get
to Mars that you need to get to Mars
right so you're mostly pushing fuel
around the nice thing about photonic
propulsion is that you don't have to
move the fuel around you are you are
shooting the
if you will at the spacecraft imperative
buy so so imagine you've got a hose and
and and then at the other end of the of
the the driveway you want to move some
stuff off the driveway some leaves you
spray the hose at the leaves and then
all the leaves go through right off your
driveway and you're like ah good old
clean driveway the neighbors are gonna
be so envious so it's like that except
instead of a hose of water
it's a hose of photons a laser beam that
you pointed a mirror and the photons
which do not have mass but do have
energy and momentum remarkably enough
can transfer that momentum onto a
spacecraft from a centralized place
where those photons are being generated
by some extremely powerful laser mm-hmm
and then that laser will shoot at the
the reflectors on the spacecraft which
would have to be fairly light it needs
to start and move it to extremely fast
speeds with this extremely powerful
laser now you got to build a really
powerful laser and you're probably not
going to be shooting it from the surface
of earth there's a problem here which is
that the laser would vaporize some of
the atmosphere would have a hard time
getting out of the atmosphere so you
probably want the laser to be in space
but you wouldn't have to carry this fuel
because the fuel is made of photons and
photons do not have mass so but you
wouldn't be carrying them with you would
actually be shooting the photons from a
place probably in orbit around Earth or
on the moon and and they've been doing
research on this and it is a it's a
system that works that functions they've
done it in the lab but what you have to
and NASA is currently you know obviously
thinking whirring front trying to figure
out how this work but you have to you
have to build a really massive laser and
probably you would be for this initial
step you'd be sending a fairly light
things a thing like maybe like a 200
pound or 100 kilogram spacecraft to Mars
but you could do it really fast which
would be amazing because the solar
system is really big so big that you
know Voyager 1 only just left the solar
system after being launched in 1977
so if you want to get and and also
because this is a good way of
transferring energy and you don't need
to haul your fuel along with you this
would be a sort of the way if you wanted
to send a probe to another star hmm
that's exciting
yeah but not as exciting as AFC
Wimbledon's heroic
one-nil victory against Carlisle United
think you will remember that uh we were
supposed to play Carlisle United a
couple weeks right
but the soggy pitch that game was won by
waterlogged pitch why don't live
pictures had a great season a disease to
bear in second but we beat Carlisle
United you remember in the game before
that we'd beat Barnet and in the game
before that we beat Luton Town the same
team we beat in 2011 that means I'm not
good at math Hank but I believe that
means that AFC Wimbledon is won three
straight games is that unusual it is
unusual yes and unusual for everybody in
the league as usual to win three
straight games um here is the most
exciting part of this AFC Wimbledon are
currently in fifth place in league 2
with 15 games to go Wow so what what are
the top three don't have to compete at
all the top three automatically go to
legal do they still play in the playoffs
just for fun no they choose not to
anybody take those they take those days
off okay and then four five six and
seven enter into a playoff and the
winner of that playoff
goes up to Ligue 1 only one team from
four or five six seven goes up to week
one but right now AFC Wimbledon is in
fifth and and crazily they are not that
far behind third so I'm I am officially
dreaming but I'm starting to think about
dreaming of automatic promotion but this
has been an amazing amazing run that
Wimbledon have been on they've had a
great season so some other teams have
had some bad games we we have Annotated
from other teams having some bad games
but also Wimbledon is just winning all
of their games and like if you win all
your games you go up like and so I'm
starting now here's the crazy thing Hank
I actually looked the other day so
the third tier in English football is
called Ligue 1 helpfully and I actually
looked at the average attendance for all
the teams currently in Ligue 1 and they
are all at least 3,000 more than AFC
Wimbledon's stadium can contain all of
them yeah every team in the longest one
is three thousand more than AFC
Wimbledon's stadium can contain the
highest one is like 20,000 so you've got
you guys gonna get that new stadium
built so obviously we have to get the
new stadium built but also it makes me
think that if we were to go up to Ligue
1 somehow that would be a wonderful
season but I can't imagine how that'd be
sustainable but I mean maybe who knows I
mean you know obviously no one thought
that AFC Wimbledon would go from the
ninth tier of amateur football and be
promoted five times in nine years so who
knows who knows who knows I am starting
to dream it is incredibly fun it's so
exciting the goal by the way was scored
by 34 year-old Paul Robinson a
journeyman centre-back who was up for a
free kick I I myself am only 38 years
old
meaning that seeing Paul met Paul
Robinson scored that goal and began to
dream that perhaps in addition to
sponsoring AFC Wimbledon they might have
a place for me on the club you know the
great tragedy is John huh we're in this
house yeah that our parents have rented
yeah and it has an Xbox yeah but you
didn't bring FIFA ID I had no idea that
they would have it does one of these
like ancient Xboxes from way back in
2008 it is an old ax but at least FIFA
10 or something yeah I could have just
absolutely schooled you yeah and and
yeah it would have been fun well but
instead we'll just play that bad
mariokart rip-off
yeah over and over again sonic the
hedghog mariokart rip-off denny's I
don't like to criticize it because I
know that a lot of the developers for
Sonic the Hedgehog's racing game our big
fans of Dear John attack but boy it is
not
great game you guys should have worked
harder on that one feels like you might
have phoned it in it's a pretty obvious
Mario Kart it seems a little bit like
you know God took every single thing
that Mario Kart has and just did that
but maybe with a little bit more
terrible just terrifying colors yeah
just worse it everywhere my favorite
thing in that game is that instead of
green and red turtle shells there are
green and red boxing gloves but they do
the exact same thing and the red one is
heat-seeking just like in Mario Kart and
that green one just shoots straight
yeah and bounces it was like a shell
yeah beautiful so I am actually going to
AFC Wimbledon's game against Oxford
United this weekend which will be in the
past when this video was uploaded but I
am incredibly excited because it's just
AFC Wimbledon are suddenly there in
fifth so we'll see this is a huge game
against Oxford United because Oxford
United is third Oxford is sitting there
in that automatic promotion spot so if
they win that game the math even with
you know so many games left like it
doesn't doesn't work in Wimbledon favor
right if we win that game I'm gonna be
properly dreaming all right that's
exciting we've got a couple of updates
from the last time we had a podcast many
people yeah many people wrote in to say
that when we said that if you were
bleeding out of any orifice you should
go see a doctor
yeah I wanted to remind us that in fact
about half of the people you have that
happen regularly it is a healthy normal
thing you have happened so I apologize
for being so dudes we were blinded as we
so often are by the patriarchy by the
patriarchy if by our own experience yes
we also got a comment speaking of places
where we were blind from social about
social identity from Rachel who points
out that when I said in the safe by the
Bell question last week you can't
actually separate who you want from how
people see you because identity is
something that is hashed out in social
spaces that that may be true of ego
identity but that stereotypes about how
people see you you know obviously that
can be extremely destructive and she
I think it is possible and positive to
be able to separate who you are from the
stereotypes that other people have about
you or your group for example all of the
research about a phenomenon known as
stereotype threat is basically about the
benefits of separating yourself from how
people see your group so that's
important and interesting kind of
correction comment and we also had a
bunch of we had two different people who
wrote in about the phrase turn of the
century yes first someone who is a
linguist and has access to linguistic
databases and was able to identify the
first time turn of the century I
appeared in print and it was in the
1890s to refer to the turn of the
previous century from 1700 to 1800 Wow
and was only used like three or four
times though in that entire century to
refer to that so obviously just a clever
turn of phrase and then in the 1920s it
became used much more frequent like 1921
I believe use it in 2021 and not until
then
but Jacob has suggested that since we do
not have the opportunity to do this very
often we should in fact be using the
phrase turn of the millennium there's no
reason not to we can why not do that in
order to avoid confusion in this one
century when we can yeah we probably
won't be around for the turn of the next
millennium so we should we should not
enjoy the phrase well that is available
to us also we got this comment from
Andrew more of a question but a very
interesting one Dear John and Hank I
dropped my four sided banana in the
sewer half a year ago but fortunately
managed to fish it out it's been in my
cupboard ever since so it's several
months past its expert
part of it has been eaten by mold but
the rest is still intact if a bit worse
for wear
is it safe to cut the banana up and put
it in my cereal also I collect water
from stagnant pools around my
neighborhood and use that instead of
milk thanks Andrew that's under full you
could have I bet you could have you
could have packed at least three or four
more dear Hank and John references and
in their meeting of which oh my god it's
burning alright John what are they learn
today well nothing
this is not it this was not this is not
a podcast where we learned anything
we learned that there is winter on Mars
we learned that that only recently did
Congress decide that they that they're
the Constitution's request for their
consent meant anything at all which I
did not I honestly did not know and I'm
fast I probably I talked to you more
about to the did Supreme Court I
probably I probably got the decade wrong
but it was sometime in the 20th century
there were a few things before that but
it was really only then that they got
the real real I want to say bug in the
britches but I'm not sure that that's
actually a phrase but I think it should
be fair I got a real bug in their
britches about Supreme Court nomination
it sounds like it should be I'd Google
it but the internet doesn't work up here
what else did we learn today Hank
we learned that 13 year olds in Germany
have better grammar than the average
American we learned that John is not not
a real not a real hugger
I mean I like hogging but it just should
be most almost exclusively an arms event
yes we learned that John believes that
hugs should be almost exclusively
involving arms and potentially in
extreme intimate circumstances collar
rooms yeah I'm ok with collar bones
thanks for listening to our podcast
which is edited by Nicholas Jenkins our
intern is Claudia Morales you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com or use
the hashtag on Twitter Facebook wherever
you hashtag dear Hank and John our theme
music is from gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]